there was an idea to bring together a  group of remarkable people to see if we  could become something bold no does the  wrong movie sorry coach boy  I'll be there ASAP  No you can team up with frozen by old  frozen wherever toys are sold leave the  shank in the world to the moon  [Music]  watch out bad guys no you can team up  with Elastigirl  I love my last girl together you can  stop your elastic her over ever toys are  sold  [Music]  it might get weird  heavy weight problems need heavyweight  solutions mr. Pennell is nice here oh no  you can team up with mr. incredible is  mom's new job she's an advocate for  superheroes but I thought superheroes  were still illegal  [Applause]  so things haven't spiraled out of  control the moment I left looks normal  to me  [Applause]  suited up I'll be there ASAP  it's up to us  hey little baby pigs are see incredible  Stewie yep she gets down repeat  you